my place to be a servant to our
president and all mankind because
together we can together we are and
together we will be to change that we
see nearly four years ago America's best
and brightest celebrities bravely
pledged to serve the most powerful man
on the planet Barack Obama with the 2012
election upon us we decided to check in
on how they're doing with their pledges
I pledge to turn the lights off that I
used to leave lights on but we want to
conserve energy so I'm eternal I saw you
turn the lights off yeah call him back
when his plane lands I pledge to sell my
obnoxious car and buy a hybrid I hope
you sold that of not just hat too I
pledge I pledge you always represent my
country with pride dignity and honesty
he seems really torn between dignity and
honesty I pledge to be of service to
Barack Obama
[Music]
I've always pledged to serve my William
Howard Taft for the environment I pledge
to flush only after a deuce never a
single I because together we can
together we are together we will be to
change that me see
[Music]